welcome everyone
bye everyone my name is Earhart great
I'm a PhD shooting over the center Civic
Media feel like a media I have the honor
of introducing kind of the foremost
researchers on certain media and social
movements right now excellent ok
cutting-edge work you've been doing on
the Internet research agency and and
their activity on Twitter so let me just
kind of do the the background profile of
Dean if you you haven't had a chance to
read it in the on the poster
so right now he's the associate
professor in the School of Media and
journalism UNC Chapel Hill I just work
covers two major areas of scholarship
one is political expression through
digital media and two is data science
and computational methods for analyzing
large digital data sets he's an author
or co-author where the 30 journal
articles book chapters are public
reports in addition how editing one
scholarly book he's also served as a PI
on grants with knight Foundation's
transfer foundation u.s. Institute of
Peace not only that he's also been
developing research grading software for
several years some of you may have
actually used it but it gets to a recall
for inner coder of reliability for
content analysis is TSM package on
analyzing our scale network data social
media as well as the factors for
collecting data from Facebook have to be
public this is a really awesome dude
who's been that's the kind of fusion of
thinking about how do we collect this
data firsthand and then think as a
social scientist does to ask the right
questions
that they come away with you know
interesting answers about the fella
that's really dominating kind of the
moment of democracy and so we're
fortunate to have him here at MIT I mean
it should be no no signal to the quality
of the speech that I have to go well
thank you Earhart in absentia so the
presentation I'm going to give to you
today is somewhat low on presentational
polish and because I spent most of the
time actually working on the
presentation materials because this is
late-breaking stuff as I'll demonstrate
so what I'm gonna talk about here is
Russian disinformation which if you've
been paying attention to the news has
been all over it lately I did some
analysis of one specific organization
that produces this kind of content known
as the internet research agency I'm
trying to do some a couple of things
here I want to be able to do some cool
empirical analysis of this data but I
also want to be able to push theory
which is a lot which is something that
not everyone who deals with this kind of
intensive trace big data social media
stuff is really interested in but I am
because I feel that dumb I want the
research that I do to speak to the
concerns of people who are really trying
to theorize about it ask what it means
and how it relates to other types of
concepts and also people who everyday
people who just encountered this some
kind of content online as they sort of
go about their daily civic and political
lives so with that I'm just gonna go
ahead and get started I'm going to talk
for maybe 40 to 45 minutes and then
hopefully there'll be some time for
conversation also coming up if you read
the if you saw some of the promotional
materials around this there will be a
live research portion of this tempting
fate so please don't be like my
undergrad staring at me blankly when I
asked you for participation so that is
forthcoming you are forewarned all right
so what comes to your mind when you
think of trolls
don't be like wonder grows what was that
anger okay what else you have to do two
common threads right yeah hatred lots of
anger hatred youtube comment threads
ignorance right you went you might
picture somebody like this right
or maybe if you're like more on this
sort of reddit 4chan tip hopefully most
most of you aren't you might picture
this guy you may if you have been
following the IR a story you might
picture somebody like this this is a
woman named Russian freelance journalist
named Ludmila South Chuck who in 2015
went undercover as an employee at the
internet research agency which is a
so-called troll farm whose purpose is to
spread propaganda Russian propaganda on
social media around the world now I call
them a so-called troll farm because I
don't think trolling is really the best
analytical lens to apply to what they're
doing scholars who study trolls tell us
that most of them do it for the lulz
right so they do it for like
schadenfreude uh and you know digital
sadism you might call it right the IRA
are a different breed for a couple of
reasons first of all they get paid which
like real trolls just only wish they
could be right and secondly they don't
discriminate quite as much they do
discover it a little bit but they don't
discriminate quite as much in terms of
who they are trying to target and as
I'll show later on in the presentation
they do target across a wide range of
the ideological spectrum and their
operations here in the States although
that degree of targeting is not
unlimited or complete so I felt like I
needed it so even though the word
trolling has really been applied to this
kind of activity a lot in the media I
felt like I needed to get beyond that
analytical concept to really get a
handle on on what the IRA is doing so an
obvious place to start here conceptually
is with propaganda and since it's become
it's been a core concern of the study of
communication at least since the days of
the Institute of propaganda analysis
that's 1937 to 1942
you forgot and probably before right it
was built goes all the way back goes
back many many years the term itself
dates back from you know the sixth
seventeenth century I believe some of
you may be familiar with Herman and
Chomsky's propaganda model of mass media
which tries to explain how mainstream
news and other media serve
propagandistic functions what we're
seeing on social media is at once more
and less subtle than that yes okay thank
you all right
now where was I
so it looks more and less subtle than
sort of the propaganda model of Herman
and Chomsky here so you know it's it's
more subtle because we don't know who's
behind the messages which a long after
they've already gone viral if we ever
find out right they're also less subtle
because the messages themselves are many
of them are very very over-the-top right
extreme they're outrageous
they're intended to provoke almost to
the way and also the some of these
subtle law tells us Alice isms that they
have are so explicit and so direct that
looking at it with the benefit of
hindsight you know you kind of want to
kick yourself for not realizing the ruse
earlier or at least I did you know use
like I couldn't tell that wasn't you
know Russian propaganda but you know
nobody expects Russian propaganda
apparently so that's uh that's how that
works
so disinformation as many of you may be
aware is a very specific type of
propaganda some claim that the term was
coined to come is it's Russian origin
but some claim that the term was coined
by styling himself over that itself may
be a point of disinformation right so
the term is sometimes confused with
misinformation which is like inadvertent
it which is like incorrect information
that is inadvertently spread but I find
the distinction useful and so on
going to maintain it in my research and
in this presentation so I defined
disinformation as the surreptitious
purposeful distribution of messages
intended to harm targets and/or benefit
sources right now what's really
important to mention here is that this
information isn't necessarily always
false right a lot of what the IRA said
was true and verifiable they linked to
the mainstream news organizations the
facts they're not disputed you know if
anything the the truth value of the IRAs
messages is probably best captured by
concepts like reckless disregard for the
truth from libel law and [ __ ] from
epistemology right you know they'll say
whatever works regardless of its truth
or falsehood right so that's not the
point the point is you know does it sort
of get the job done and that's what
they're interested in let me break down
this definition a bit more because it
has these five components or so four or
five and I want to just go over each one
of them because each one is actually
really important the last two are kind
of entertained you interchangeably
optional but you have that at least one
of them so these are the hidden source
the source knowledge of methods purpose
or yes the intention to harm targets and
attention to benefit source that's what
I think I okay so it probably goes
without saying that this information
doesn't work if the targets know what
the real sources right so this is why in
the pre-digital age most of the major
forms this information took was one of
the major forms of disinformation took
was like forged memos like real
cloak-and-dagger stuff right so like oh
here's a forged memo that such a such
high-level operative or agent or you
know cabinet member is planning to knock
over this or that country and so in some
ways it gains its currency from its
plausibility but of course nevertheless
in the details it is of course false and
then what but then of course when the
truth comes to light the whole thing
falls apart so a major part a major task
of disinformation lies in trying to
that from happening so when we talk
about source knowledge of message
purpose there's a real difference here
in the difference between this and
misinformation really comes out because
within misinformation people pass along
content if they don't realize is
problematic but of course this
information agents know full well what
their messages are intended to do and
what their messages are the content
every part of it that's true every part
of it is false and every part of it lies
in that great gray area right in the
middle now there is a lot of recent
research and communication studies in
southern political science Brendan Nyhan
at Dartmouth has been at the forefront
of this on misinformation to trying to
correct it however this particular point
the source knowledge of message purpose
indicates that most solutions to the
misinformation problem will not work
with this information right so a big
part of misinformation is you know first
of all convincing people that they're
incorrect and then you can sort of work
on the strategies that help them get
over that but when folks know that what
they're doing is harmful and problematic
all along then you can't really use the
same trap tactics to try to to try to
counteract that and of course that
brings me to my next component which is
intention to harm okay so this
information isn't necessarily false
though that what often is but if it's
not a benefit that was not intended to
harm sources or and/or benefit sources
harm targets and our benefit sources
sorry it doesn't really count as
disinformation in this it bears some
similarities to public relations
although public relations isn't always
surreptitious and actually I would apply
that more to the benefit source than the
harming targets although PR can have
both effects so speaking of which yes
that is a topic that I am going to look
into in a future paper because I'm just
gonna say this really quickly the data
set that I have access to is only the
IRA tweet are any tweets themselves but
I think it you know simple logic would
dictate that you know they can't spread
this on their own so I think what I'm
building so what I'm building to I think
eventually in this line of research is
sort of a disinformation misinformation
kind of like you know in from well it's
a message ecosystem right in which the
origin is sort of disinformation 'el and
then it requires unwilling and unknowing
participants to be able to spread it I
think you're absolutely right about that
yes so getting back to the pension
benefits source so sometimes target comm
and source benefit are the same so this
is often true international relationship
right you lose I win and so what this
information is used as a weapon of
warfare of course between two rival
countries you know there can be some
disagreement and so what's interesting
about this and you'll see this you can
talk about this later if you're
interested is there can be some
disagreement about the degree of harm
that this information actually causes so
some people have said this and I can
look this up for you if you want the
citations and so some people say well
you know what these folks are saying I
actually agree with so like who cares if
they're foreign you know this
information propaganda ages well I care
but you know apparently some people
don't and so if what is being said is
functionally indistinguishable from what
like real people actually say and there
are questions about the degree of harm
but but there is that intention there
and certainly the intention to benefits
source as well so there's some other
related terms you may have heard that it
work but that also that some of this
work goes under there is influence
operations and psychological operations
which of course has a major military
connotation and interestingly enough the
US government readily admits to being
engaged and in tune with operations
psychological operations they do not
readily admit to being involved in
disinformation so the connotation is a
sort of a big factor they're active
measures as a term that is closely
associated with thumb clan
in Soviet propaganda from the 60s
through the 80s of which this
information is only one but that's where
the whole you know forged memo thing
comes in you know leaked information one
of the major aspects of the active
measures was the myth that the US
government created the HIV virus which
is still believed by many many people
but Soviet disinformation agents played
a major role in distributing and
spreading that that that rumor
then there's the Soviet term mask arroba
which is Russian for disguise and that's
more of a military term it's associated
with Russian military tactics it
includes things in addition to
disinformation as physical camouflage
official government actions intended to
mislead enemies and so you can also look
at this information as one of the items
under that umbrella and then of course
there is the more recent concept of
computational of propaganda which is a
term that's been you know popularized by
Phil Howard was also Mike on my dis
committee full disclosure and his
colleague Sam Sam Willie at Oxford and
that really refers to propaganda that's
created on social media often
algorithmically or by cybernetically
enhanced individual ease individuals now
of course not all comp taste on
propaganda state-sponsored
and if you know Phil's work you know
that he also cast a pretty wide net in
terms of what he includes in that but
there's a strong argument to be made
that the IRA also fits into that
category so in my read of this
literature there's really three main
types of research so first you've got
well first of all want to say the
research in this area is actually very
sporadic so if you know if like thriving
research in this area that I don't know
about please let me know because what I
found is just various bits and pieces
around and maybe it goes under under
other names besides the ones that I
showed in the previous slide so you've
got sort of purely conceptual and
definitional work so you've got a lot of
papers that are like here's what this
information is here's what extant
measures are here's you know what masks
are OVA is and so that's that's really
great a sort of a backdrop but it's not
empirical and the use sort of examples
but they don't really get into it very
far
then we've got case studies lots of case
studies were those zero in on one
incident or one sort of small piece of
this and and really really get into the
nitty-gritty of that but a lot of those
are purely descriptive a lot of those
are not peer reviewed they're the sort
of reports that are issued by think
tanks that sort of thing and in the last
one that we've started to see emerge in
the past few years is data-driven
computational analyses of the social
media traces of a lot of this type of
stuff and so Phil Howard and Sam Willie
have been at the forefront of this
putting out lots of reports from their
computational propaganda project
and so the advantage of that is they're
able to circulate it and get it out
there into the world but it's not peer
reviewed and it doesn't really feel
theory and so and off you also have a
great degree of methodological
sophistication which you know plays
really well with the information science
computer science crowds not as much with
the social science crowds so now I don't
mean to claim that this is everything we
need to know but one thing that I think
would really help move us to the next
step in our exploration of
disinformation is some baseline evidence
of you know and some salade scale and
baseline evidence of who is being
targeted right because not everyone is
an equal risk of being targeted at this
information this deployment and by
analyzing the assumed identities of the
social media accounts they're
associating with this information we can
start to understand as I'll demonstrate
who their intended audiences are right
what is being said which perhaps goes
without saying all right the content of
what it is what it is and what it isn't
and then of course which identities and
tactics are most successful right
because you know the IRA as I'll
demonstrate is nothing if not you know
invented it tried a whole lot of
different things and only a few things
actually worked and so one of the aims
of this research is to try to figure out
in terms of message distribution using
that as a dependent variable trying to
discover exactly how that works that
piece I'm still in the middle of I have
some very preliminary data on that but
the other two I've sort of gotten a
little further into so the Internet
research agency
I'm using them as a sort of a test case
here and the idea is that research that
comes after this will be able to build
on it
this building is their office in st.
Petersburg right this is job people show
up they work 12 hours a day pumping out
also its propagate or they did right
before they were indicted by robert
muller but we'll get to that so just a
little bit of history here information
on the IRA is slowly dribbled out into
the West
starting at 2014 when the first news
article is written about them by a
journalist at BuzzFeed there was a very
popular article written in 2015 by
Adrian Chen for the New York Times that
really really got into to what they do
and how they work but until recently was
very difficult to study their actual
content because we didn't know exactly
who they who the accounts were now on
October 1st of 2017 November 1st excuse
me
well actually actually back in October
of 2017 a Russian magazine called RBC
wrote an article in Russian that really
revealed a lot of details that were
previously not known about the IRA
including some of their handles and so
that article published maybe 20 a couple
dozen maybe 20 to 30 handles and that
was out there I do Google Translate a
bit as half-decent so I was able to like
get the gist of it and then on November
1st the US House Intelligence Committee
released 2005 to 2,700 552 275 - yes
IRA Associated Twitter handles I was
very busy that evening so trying to pull
that out of the PDF that they posted
when they have to talk about that David
deployment folks so they really sat and
so you know that sort of set everybody
who had been interested in this I'm sure
scrambling toward their pre-existing
data sets because Twitter and Facebook
which was the other major social media
platform that the IRA infiltrated had
scrubbed all the content of this off of
their sites so there's no way to get to
it and and all that was was uh was gone
so and of course it was a more
indictment a couple weeks ago and that
has really sort of pushed this story
forward and kept it in the public eye
you know they're still being stories
being written about it which you know in
this
like lasting beyond the 24-hour news
cycle is like a huge achievement so I'm
really shocked that they're still
talking about this so let me just go
over a few basic facts I need to talk
about my data in a bit but I'm so
they've been active since summer 2013 at
least since then they have a budget of
annual budget of 1.25 million u.s.
dollars so you know like pretty cheap
right like just a just a rounding error
in the Kremlin operating budget really
something somewhere between 80 and 600
employees but if a bit of a confidence
interval there so there was some
complete conflicting accounts on that
and that it may have shrunk our recently
especially after the election it said
that they required a minimum of a
hundred comments per day per employee so
you know they got busy caps bonuses for
provoking strong reactions so you know
you really throw elements to getting
into it that was one thing that they
were all bosses were really interested
in the traffic and hoaxes outrageous
opinions and verify facts so just a nice
wonderful epistemological slurry of all
sorts of stuff in there right that
targets all over the world the US UK
Ukraine Russia you name it right they
did it and so you know and they're also
one of many operations we don't know how
many this is one that's verified it's
been a lot of work done on this and so
we're fairly sure that the folks that
are involved in this were actually
involved in the disinformation yeah so
some of the news articles that have been
done by independently operating
journalists have been able to
substantiate this with the help of I
believe what the help documents provided
by folks like the journalist who was
actually a mole in their organization so
yeah that's been infant ever
independently verified multiple times
yeah yeah so there so they are there
they are a company that is visited I'm a
government contractors right they're a
company that's paid by the Kremlin yes I
just pulled that piece right out of one
of the articles um I had to look to try
to find that there wasn't a whole lot of
elaboration on that I would guess volume
would be a factor there I don't know how
much like salmon analysis they got into
but like sheer volume would might might
justify that but I'm not a hundred
percent sure about that
more faxes so we know they were there
active on Twitter Facebook YouTube also
tumblr which is not on here so you 2700
552 ira link twitter accounts i never
first time in 2017 all scrubbed prior to
the release of those of those accounts
twitter claims that it's aidid 3814 ira
accounts at the January 18th that's a
that's an increase over a thousand from
what the the the House Intelligence
Committee released on November 1st
they also ebo did anybody get one of
these emails from interacting with ira
content twitter folks one person right
and so twitter emailed or message
somehow six hundred seventy seven
thousand seven hundred seventy five
users who interacted with ira contact
however that number only counts
engagements that's it's like clicks or
retweets or likes or replies not views
so the actual number of people who saw
it is heavily much much greater and
twitter also announced in a blog post
where they discussed this that they had
one hundred seventy five thousand nine
hundred ninety three or IRA tweets
however the data set that I'm about to
describe actually contains more than
that so that may indicate it put is
wrong or the data set is wrong you need
to figure that out so as I mentioned all
data was removed from the sites as it
was discovered and so researchers you
really want to study this have three
options they can draw their own
pre-existing data sets for IRA content
which I did I've got some of this in a
data set that I'm gonna use in a future
project I'm actually not gonna talk
about that today secondly they can
smoothly in an internet archive which I
can help you with because I've done it
but it took me a while to figure out so
I don't want anybody have to go through
that again the Internet Archive I found
about seven thousand tweets after I D
duplicated so they've got some stuff and
the nice thing about that is it's not
going away and then finally there is the
NB c-- data set which is very
interesting
so on valentine's day NB c-- news of all
places releases two hundred thousand
over two hundred thousand ira tweets
from sources that they are unwilling to
name they put it literally in the middle
of the
a CA posted CSV in the middle of this
article and so that's where it is
and so I've looked at it and I've looked
at other Ayari datasets and I'm really
sure it's genuine there were a couple
other things I want to check out you
know they in the article they mentioned
I'm like well the sources realize that
technically posting this is violated for
the Terms of Service so we don't want to
tell you who they are but the data
looked pretty good I verified I'm by
looking at some of the duplicate tweet
IDs that they've got in there so at
least some of it is jobs with what I've
got
unfortunately the data are a little bit
messy it's clearly been cobbled together
from multiple sources there are some
fields missing so I've had to work with
work around that but this is probably
your best bet if you really want to
study this stuff and that's what I've
been so I've been working on it for gosh
what is it like Valentine's Day it was
two weeks ago so yes but over the last
two weeks using some techniques that I
had refined and working with some of the
smaller data sets before and that is the
content that I'm going to present in the
empirical portion of this talk so here's
the basic descriptives right so total
number of 2752 the combined data set
between the internet archive and the mbc
data set is 439 unique users that is 16
percent of the u.s. house Intel accounts
and so this is just really a very large
portion not good I mean a large minority
but like you know it's sizable you know
of itself but only a small portion of
the total that were actually detected
there in the NBC data set there were
over two hundred and two thousand tweets
unique tweets in the internet archive
data set there were a little over seven
thousand when I looked at only the
English language ones which I used using
the Google language detective detecting
algorithm report for Python and I also
pulled out all duplicates I came to one
hundred ninety four thousand two hundred
fifteen tweaks and these are posted from
July 14 ending right at about the end of
September of 2017 so spending over three
years unfortunately it's hard to know
where the holes of this data aren't but
you know it's what we got
so when we're trying to look at these
specific research questions of who did
they target what did they say and what
worked to look at who did they target
I'm doing some quacks I'm confident
alysus and a little bit of qualitative
elaboration of that for what did they
say I'm doing some computational
description which I'll talk about in my
descriptive data slides and also some a
little bit of hell da which is fun and
then in terms of what worked I got to
the progression part still working on
the nested part I was literally working
on that last night so I got a little bit
of that for you but then on the plane I
thought of a much better way to do it so
that nail you're gonna get that
sometimes so let me just get into
showing you some of the descriptive
stuff here so this is IRA activity by
month this should not be at all
surprising to you you can see that there
was a tiny bit of activity starting in
the summer of 2014 and just only very
small relative spikes until the summer
of 2016 when they really ramped their
activity up for the 2016 election but as
you might not expect one thing that
might be a little bit less predictable
here is that the tapering off after the
election is not immediate so there's a
much gentler ratcheting down of activity
that we can see here and also keeping in
mind that this is not everything that
they did but of the dataset you can see
that there's a little bit of a tapering
off and then by the summer of 2017 is
pretty much crater so that's that's all
there is there it's also instructive to
take a look at account creation dates
over time right so you'll notice that
there are a very small number of account
creation base that actually predate the
supposed origin time of the IRA which is
the summer of 2013
now there were some successor
organizations to the IRA and they're not
the first according to some of the
reporting on this they're not the first
you know this information age encierro
operation that's paid for by the russian
government so some of these may have
been accounts that were associated with
some of those predecessor organizations
I'm not sure yet but you do see a major
spike during the summer of 24 2013 and
another one during the the sort of late
spring there with summer of 2014
after that you know you see some smaller
numbers here you know almost actually
doesn't even reach 20 after that summer
of 2014 so that's majority these
accounts haven't been created years
before that spike during the summer of
2016
let me just really quickly I'm gonna go
into some of the research questions now
I'm gonna talk about some of my methods
really quickly so a little bit of
non-standard content analysis where I
had my research assistants coded each
screen name and five randomly selected
tweets and they came up with the Copic
categories inductively all are raised in
all the coding what I'm gonna present
you now is um a preliminary analysis of
two of the RS and so what I did was I
simply said if those two agreed then
we're gonna confidence hit they're all
binary categories if they both agree
that there was absent or they disagreed
that we don't count that at all so at
least two individuals agreed that these
categories were present for all of the
hits though I'm about to show you the
categories were not mutually exclusive
so it could belong to to more than one
and of course the final categories who
are decided by majority gender I've got
more coders but they're not best so I
just went with these two for this
analysis so the user categories they
came up with were obvious readers across
the bob you've got proshop from the
right anti-trump from the left news
outlets black activists pro-trump from
the left anti-trump from the right fake
news and islam / middle-east and so the
this is on proportionately so this is
proportion of all users marked as ad as
of all of all the users that they
categorize all four to 39 is marked as
occupying each category so as you can
see folks trump right is the biggest one
secondly you've got anti-trump left then
you've got news outlets at little over
30 black activists i think we're exactly
thirty not a whole lot of pro-trump left
slightly less anti-trump right a little
bit of fake news and part of this has to
do with the difficulty of actually
spotting fake news in the wat at the
wild I just heard it under a class at
this people are much much worse than
they think it's like dunning-kruger
running wild and then not a just a few
of them that were attempting to pretend
as though they were you know Muslim or
Islamic or
or some that say what now the idea here
is that if you're if you're acting as
though you're a pro Trump Republican
that is an indicator of who you're
trying to target right if you're acting
this look your anti Trump luck that's
you're trying to speak to that's the
sort of inference that I'm making here
saying with black activism right okay so
if you're saying what we should really
vote for Bernie which is the thing they
said that the idea is that that did that
the community of the group is trying to
target I managed to pull some of the
some of these tweets off of the Alpha
beginner archive for you this is Pamela
more one of the most popular
conservative tweeters so you can see
some of the tweets here unfortunately
most of the videos and images were not
saved I managed to get the actual icon
for her or the image that uses us her
sort of profile image you can see some
of these right maybe the next dead be
socialism you know hating on feminists
right how to embarrass antifa Trump is
gray so you see some of the stuff might
not be necessarily Singlish scible from
the average Trump supporter I'll let you
be the judge of that
but this is just a little sample of some
of the pro Trump stuff that whether the
most popular accounts you can also take
a look at the reactions here 130 162
retweets retweeting the two hundred some
replies a bunch of likes so clearly
they're getting some some interactions
around this let's take a look at the
anti-trump left this is Robbie Delaware
I actually had a really hard time
finding good examples of anti-trump left
and part of the part of the thing is I
wanted to show it in its natural context
so there's more of this stuff that I had
in the actual data set but that's just
plain text so I wanted to show you
something so this is kind of like week
to you a little bit like let's talk
about how great Evan Lowen is and then
it's just tweeting an article about it's
sort of negative of about Trump for the
Washington Post so like not nearly as
bomb-throwing and sort of you know fiery
is the conservative stuff but you know
you can recognizably anti Trump you know
so maybe not necessarily you know from
the left but certainly certainly not
this sort of [ __ ] not the sort of anti
Trump right that you saw on the never
Trump reason where people said Oh Trump
not really a conservative that's why you
should vote for him so yes for those
accounts where they acted or were they
just right yeah so I would even look at
that
um I mean obviously if you look at this
one activity jumped a lot but I I
couldn't tell you right now I'd have to
look at the data whether they were just
sitting idle and then they just sort of
spun up you know at that time so clearly
some of the accounts were doing
something but in terms of tweets per day
I would need to go back and look at that
let's see where was I oh yes lobby down
the way also you can take a look at this
bottom tweet it's sorting a tweet about
Bryan Cranston being in a Taco Bell
commercial that's really old so they try
to get into some of the pop culture
stuff and we'll see some of that a
little bit later as well so here's an
example of a fake news outlet well we'll
be back up not in that look that there
should be fake news but or maybe
possibly that could be the truth the
truth but an outlet that is attempting
to look like a real news outlet so you
can see that that a sort of a generic
kind of handle online Cleveland but a
script written probably crib from some
actual TV station somewhere right like
Ricki news weather traffic and more from
Cleveland like sounds kind of yeah legit
couple details pop out here so portly
firstly some of the the writings a
little odd like you know what is it that
one
heartless Cleveland heartless felon
member unless the heartless felons is
the name of their gang I'm not sure what
that is you know also like for those of
you who taken journalism classes that's
editorializing right you'd be that's
something you TV journalism 101 not to
do so you know there are some tales and
here's some of the the linguistic
constructions are a little bit odd but
if you don't see you know the Russian
disinformation coming that's not really
what you're going to assume that this is
and so you could tell by the thirteen
point eight thirteen point eight
thousand followers they've got that lots
of people saw fit to to follow this and
also a preliminary analysis
indicates that the vast majority of
followers are not other IRA accounts so
they're not trying to artificially boost
their own their own numbers there for my
swamp for my squad you'll notice that
three out of the four tweets all but the
blast one are about how terrible cops
are right so bad things the cops are
doing that's what this account was
really aimed at you can also notice that
they're using kind of hip-hop inspired
you know screenname got before this
squad being a colloquial term that's
used there it's there's sort of
following this the the BLM's stereotype
they're all super and the initely
anti-cop the links themselves are
actually real as well they go to a site
called the free thought project that is
of uncertain provenance I don't know how
true that is but the links are still up
and I'm pretty sure that I don't think
that those are IRA generated but they're
still around if you want to check those
out all right so they move on a little
bit do a little bit more computational
description here so these are these are
the top hashtags is moving to what they
said so the red ones are sort of
conservative-leaning hashtags the gray
ones are if not neutral they're not
explicitly left right and the purple one
is just Trump that's me being a little
bit charitable in terms of saying well
if you want to talk about Trump it could
be positive or negative but seven out of
ten of these are very clearly
conservative in terms of their valence
and their political leaning here so and
just by way of explanation T Qaeda's top
conservatives on Twitter magma is Magha
PJ net is patriot journalist Network
seacock is Christian conservatives on
Twitter and the rest of those I think
are more or less self explanatory so
here's where they were sort of spending
a lot of their time engaging with these
kinds of hashtags so most reference
users and so references includes
retweets mentions and replies and so
we've got a little bit more diversity
here Donald Trump is number one
Clinton's second blicker is sort of a
black african-american
oriented news source that kind of still
up so I seen what's the IRA let's say
you got at midnight is a really
interesting one people watch the show at
midnight Comedy Central show so some of
these IRA accounts we're trying to post
jokes and stuff to the @midnight account
so they've got all these hashtags where
people try to post jokes they talk about
the funniest ones on TV I guess and so
really good shows to show how they were
trying to engage with pop culture here
you've also got conservative
conservative Xion who is an actual
conservative whose account is so hot
POTUS which could have gone the reason
why that's purple is you know free
inauguration it was Obama post was Trump
of course and a few news outlets Fox
News CNN not prison planet but you know
you see those as well so let me just
talk to talk a little about how I did my
topic modeling here I had it I go get it
tweets by user first because you know
doing topic modeling on very short text
is very difficult
aggregating by my user had some really
nice results as I'll show you stamp it
using LibreOffice slash chrome stemmer
which works better than the default one
and the software I was using I had a
custom stop word list and I remove stuff
from I remove very short and very long
words most of the very long words were
like URLs since I got rid of those i
generated five models for each of five
Ches Ches five seven nine eleven and
thirteen and that was just based on
qualitative analysis lower than five
most of the topics were kind of mixed
together then because a lot of sense
above thirteen there were a lot of
duplicate topics and so we do the math
it ends up being twenty twenty-five
topics and so what it was I had my
research assistants read each topic and
assign an inductive mutual exclusive
category
I didn't loose it here what whereas I
didn't before because topic sis was
short I looked at the top ten highest
probability terms for each one they also
did a coherence rating and the idea
behind that is the the the extent to
which the terms matched up with the
theme that they chose so if they were
all related then give it a ten if all
the terms were unrelated to one another
they give it a one and then so on and so
forth up and down the scale and so I
wanted to do this to be able to use all
the models rather than saying this is
definitely the Kay that's the best K and
going with that
let me show you the results of this
really quickly so the categories let me
just go over these so we've got election
2016 which is number one purple that's
you know left and right conservative
politics is second hashtag games and so
this would be like trending topics and
also the @midnight stuff black activist
terms or topics were after that music
podcast film was strangely big news
categories which were which were things
like news sports whether you know
business that sort of thing and then a
small number this also starts at point
five so and that's a Isis Syria and
Middle East actually think is nothing
wrong so uh no sorry that's point oh
five no this is my chart type yeah brick
data seconds right there so let's take
leave some of these topics election 2016
you can catch the theme there Trump
politics Clinton this is these are the
top ten most likely terms on this topic
Clinton Donald news relatively non part
of them these are terms that both sides
we probably use the conservative
politics is distinguished by its
hashtags in terms that are definitively
associated with the right-hand side of
the aisle
chica PJ net Trump for president wake up
America refugee cruise to a Islam kills
definitively right wing with this topic
let me show you just a couple more of
these
we've got black activist the terms here
with things like black black lives
matter police white cop p2 which is a
progressive hashtag racism black Twitter
or racist kill probably should have stem
those two terms didn't work on that
hashtag games and so here's what the
hashtag games looks like Christmas
aftermath 2016 in four words I have a
right to know
secondhand gifts it's risky to sometimes
it's okay to so it's like fill in the
blank not explicitly political but
allows the IRA to sort of get if some of
those folks that aren't paying quite as
much attention to politics at least
that's my theory
I'm just really cook to show you this
thing on like mean topic model coherence
basically this was the extent to which
the terms in these topics actually
matched up with each of these or this
objective range here and so this is just
the average top model coherence for all
of the ones that were labeled as
election 2016 so that had the highest
five mana coherence with almost nine
term
out of ten matching in each of these
topics conservative politics second
music podcast film is third and so on
and so forth
news categories is actually the least
coherent one and so basically that was a
topic that was often mixed with other
stuff but the ones that were solidly
most and had the word color currents and
[ __ ] and so the most focus or I liked
were the sort of explicitly political
ones at least the first two and then you
get into music podcast film in the black
activist all right we have come to the
live data analysis portion of this talk
alright so it turns out that one of the
nice ways of analyzing sentiment here is
not using sort of explicitly crazy
sentiment analysis algorithms but simply
looking at the most common hashtags that
were posted in association with various
keywords and so if you'll allow me I'll
get them go ahead and give you a
demonstration here so let me just show
you this real fast let's see if we can
do this oh there's my code yes I use
Idol and I'm definitely proud of it all
right let's see here come on what's
worked okay so this is me move this over
here what but there it is hang on
terribly exciting oh that's why that's
why it's not moving don't do this to me
hang on one second oh there it is let's
see if they're gonna do this
yeah I know right like it works it works
perfectly you know on you know what hang
on a second I'm actually gonna mirror
this for just a second I'm gonna flip
this so may just duplicate real quick
we're gonna do that oh sorry Kate
don't do that we're gonna revert is that
oh now you see what I'm saying great
okay perfect so let's see if this pops
up all right there we go so let's see if
this will allow me to enter team it so
I'm just gonna start with a couple first
imma start with is Trump so let's see if
this does it for me really Wow so that
managed to crash my system excellent so
that's that's terribly exciting so
that's you know there's your live data
analysis I was going to show you was
okay yes what I was going to show you
was basically an example of where if you
type in some keywords that are relevant
to the election Trump for example will
turn up a lot of pro Trump hashtags
Hillary turns up a lot of anti Hillary
hashtags interestingly I was also going
to show terms like liberal and
conservative which if you type of
conservative there's lots of different
sort of conservative issues liberals a
lot of anti liberal stuff so it's a nice
way of sort of doing this let's see if
my system will pop back up and we can
tempt fate again yeah I am you know you
think that just hooking up the the
screen here wouldn't wouldn't cause such
such issues but we'll um I'll try this
one more time and therefore crashes
again definitely done if you'll just
give me one second cuz I thought I
thought it was you know it's so great
because you like when you're planning
this like in your office your the
comments gonna go so great then you pull
it out and you're like oh gosh not
really
alright let's see here we'll say so
we're gonna do all right so let's put
that back up and see if we can do this
without crashing the entire system all
right let's see here so I'm gonna pull
that up let's see all right
we're gonna do that nice it's right
there so we're gonna try this there we
go so let's see here
come on don't crash ah there it is
alright okay so there you go see so
trump trump politics time 16 2014
president Trump train never Hillary now
do Hillary alright there we go
never Hillary Clinton crooked Hillary
Trump for president things more trusted
than Hillary very nice
politics tea cot I'm just expand this
real quick I don't want to tempt fate
but can I have some suggestions from the
audience yes Bernie all right show me
Bernie
all right feel the Bern Bernie a bust
never Hillary bring Bernie back with us
no but the numbers are much lower than
you saw you're in the hundreds high
hundreds for Hillary Clinton here you
top out at 64 so some pro Bernie stuff
but a lot less of that what else you got
actually don't think is gonna be a whole
lot of that but because the data set
ends at UM to get any more stuff nothing
so the data set ends in them September
2017 so and also the the activity was
rationing down at that point so that I
wouldn't know yeah let's try it out FBI
politics maggoty [ __ ] Clinton nothing
too interesting
yes that's good let's see if they got
any hot stuff in here yeah nothing about
that no Dino Dino deep dat okay we'll
just do that no da PL okay so they were
also engaging around I know DP know the
APL
okay let's try let's try we'll just try
black about that we'll just try that so
yeah so they were engaged around some
these black issues black lives matter
black Twitter Trump Oscar has no color
Black History Month lacks for Trump
interesting Lee I think both of them
were involved with that right yeah so so
yeah you got some of that as well I
always get one Planned Parenthood will
just do Plan C if that comes up
believing yeah defund pp Planned
Parenthood pro-life so what so I said we
say let's see we got Putin Putin okay so
it's from favorite headline Trump you
know that's it I'll talk a whole lot
about Russia in here we can type in
Russian I'll just type Russian just to
see what they say
Russian news Syria magnet Trump Russia
Russian you know so you got a couple of
things there okay will do I'll do
standing I'll do standing rock then I'll
do micron we'll do a couple more
well do standing see if that comes
amazing so a little bit so so no DP out
stuff so a little bit of stuff and then
the other one was a macron now I did
filter that for English so the fact
there might not be a whole lot of micron
stuff immigrants okay so we'll try I
just do the singular I'll just do I'll
do I'll stem it will do immigrants cuz
I've great immigrants all of that okay
so you got some these immigrants t cot
shrunk a lot of Trump stuff so clearly
not you know probably not roodaka what's
up with daca let's see here nothing
Soros okay let's see we got restores
okay George so it's a little bit of toys
stuff not a ton yes the word fate okay
we'll try the word fake oh that's good
big news next fake Trump victim fake
Octoberfest facts
he messed us try emails will do that a
lot of those Podesta emails Hillary's
emails WikiLeaks so what box look never
works yeah oh X T got a little bit of
stuff Hannity geo PC cop from Fox News
yes I'll just do which how about that
will do cuz that would caps or anything
with not a lot not a lot on that one
see you never let's try CNN ok fake news
is number four on that one CNN's State
of the Union birtherism crooked Hillary
Magga I'm gonna do a couple more yeah I
will do one more then I look more than
yes in the back yes NRA actually you
know it's a really good one for this is
just gun I'll just do gun to aid now
flowing lot of conservative soft rap
station radio I might want to
double-check if that's the right thing
hip-hop and rap I'm not sure you know
the NRA I don't know how much rap they
listen to but was to find that out oh
yeah right okay so let's let's do gun do
you see a lot of gun stuff right
guns for NY praised for California this
was after a I'm actually forget what
that's what that's in reference to San
Bernardino right Garden City shooting PJ
net gun control this is another big one
for them alright the last thing I'm
gonna do really quickly are liberal and
conservative which I think are pretty
cool to try so we'll do liberal first so
a lot of soda anti-liberal things
liberal logic liberals Tea Party liberal
and a lot of conservative stuff mixed in
as well now let's look at the concern
let's look at the contrast first of all
remember that first number of 136 so the
in terms of the the volume here so we'll
do conserve that to spell that right so
a little bit higher but conservative Tea
Party news politics but certainly much
more conservative
terms with that keyword then you saw
with liberal which was like half
conservative in and of itself so this is
a pretty good way of doing this I'm
really glad he got up to work because I
was like I was gonna be kind of the
centerpiece of my thing so I could stop
it is do you have alright so
a little interactive thing Thanks
playing along let me start my PowerPoint
back up because if crashed
hopefully this didn't erase the changes
I made let's see now where was I I was
all the way back here I was gonna show
you this huge regression but I'm not
time to talk about it sadly let's see
what was I yeah let's get that part cuz
I'm already over time and I know there's
some things I want talking about alright
so in terms of key findings right so who
would they target pro shop conservatives
anti-trump liberals black activists
local news consumer consumers not
Hillary supporters so even though a lot
of what you know the IRAs but portrayed
to do is sort of to sow chaos and to
sort of play all sides there were
certain size that they were very
unwilling to play and the number one was
pro-hillary there was very little of
that you do see you did see some probe
Bernie stuff some pro Jill Stein stuff
but almost no pro-hillary stuff what did
they say
so topics that were talking about
include election 2016 pro-trump
Pro burning and in fact Hillary largely
black issues pop culture and
non-political so showing how they're
trying to ingratiate themselves into
trying to get into the information
environments of folks who don't
primarily consume politics also a little
bit about the Middle East which of
course is an area of great interest to
Russia given their involvement in the
Syrian war and in other areas so what
worked I can't really talk about that
because I didn't show you the regression
and also I just not have a better way to
do that so we're gonna table that
temporarily and I can sort of discuss
that during Q&A folks are really
interested but I'm working on it so
those broader implications so while the
IRA was nonpartisan they did not cover
all political bases equally which is
very important for us to remember you
know and I think that the those
omissions I think are really interesting
and instructive because they show that
not only do they aim is so chaos but
they also are trying to push certain
political agendas to the exclusion of
others I think that's something that
gets lost in this conversation sometimes
they also see blacks and conservatives
as prime targets right so people that
are in this group need to be
we're especially because US intelligence
agencies have come out and said that
Russia is gonna try to do this again at
2018 right so and also it may not be
Russia you know other folks may be
plinth sort of operating from the
Russian PlayBook and you know just like
any you know good military force they
strike at points of perceived weakness
and so that's what they're going to do
and much of the content interesting Lee
is totally innocuous not political long
like like that like they joke about
Bryan Cranston being in a an old Taco
Bell commercial right so a lot of this
stuff is just kind of you know like
random kind of funny kind of stuff but
you know you do see you know the more
nefarious edge of this pop out at
moments of political import next steps
well so I'm gonna try to get a paper out
on this any ideas what we're to submit
it to please let me know I've got some
ideas myself but if you know of places
because one thing I really want to do
with the paper on this is get it out
before the midterms because I really do
feel like people need to know about this
and I and I want to have somebody who
understands the importance of this and
also generally of scholarship impacting
the robot as opposed to all any people
that study this I want to continue to
theorize this information try to
understand it from an abstract
perspective I hope that the empirical
work here will serve as a base for a
future work in this area I've got
another I want to analyze data sets that
help to show how people react to did
this that's one thing that this dataset
doesn't do because it's only ir8 weeks
but I've got some of that I want to be
able to try to gap it more I've got some
lines on how to do that and then I'm
also interested in looking at other
state sponsored disinformation
organizations I'm not even sure what
those would be yet but I'm open if
anybody knows of what those are and how
to and how to get data on on those so
it's well past six so I'm gonna stop
there and I invite any questions you may
have and thank you for your attention
[Applause]
yes these are these are separate
profiles so in other words if you had to
let me actually back this up right so if
you look at somebody like Pamela more 13
she's on the conservative beat right and
so her whole identity is caught up in
doing that and engaging with those folks
because to be able to get the number of
followers that she had that she who
knows where there was accent woman or
not that that she had you have to be
able to be continuously engaged in that
sort of network capital is something
that you can't just sort of slough off
and then get back so people who were
engaged in this once they plugged into
one particular community they'd had a
tenant tendency to stick with it and the
same for you know for my squad right
they were on the sort of black activist
beat sure yeah so that's sort of based
on the idea for monthly right so this
idea that like attracts like so that's
that's sort of a general theoretical
basis that I bring to that and also you
know I again but that would be that
future strand of research that I just
talked about where I'm looking at the
reactions there I'll be able to
determine that a little bit better and
then I think thirdly I would say that a
lot of a lot of the content is sort of
indistinguishable from what you would
see at least from my perspective and
that's admittedly a qualitative
observation but when I look at you know
what Pamela Morris tweeting what 10 GOP
is so we got some other popular
conservative a
you know account they seem to be very
similar to what actual people who
support Trump or actually say conversely
if you look at another popular account
that I didn't show that was sort of a
black presenting account called crystal
one Johnson like I personally know
people who followed that we're like oh I
thought that was really great turns out
a sourcing propaganda so anecdotally
there's some evidence there but
obviously it doesn't even more research
I think you're right
to support that particular assumption
yeah yes apparently the Russian
government awarded her of damages for
lost wages after she was terminated from
from employment after being a mole there
there's only like $1 super super
symbolic but you see but you said she
was satisfied so I'm not sure where she
ended up but they see left her name is
Lud Millis AB Chuck I can get that
spelling for you if you really need it
yeah
so she that's that's who she is and I
need you this article as well then I got
this picture from you too so yes that's
a great question and no it's a trade
secret so that is one like major
criticism against this however
apparently it was it was enough to
convince you know the cap the House
Intelligence Committee and robert muller
who went after these folks and so on a
certain level we have to take that on on
on faith however i think that so so the
government engagement with this is one
point in favor of that another is the
fact that I don't think I actually
looked around for this I don't think
anyone claimed to be an owner of that
account in other words that their
account was incorrectly shut down as
being a Russian account it was a woman
who well there was a woman who claimed
that that was the case but it turned out
that her claim was actually not was
actually without merit so the absence of
people coming is coming up coming out
and saying I was people said I was you
know a member of the IRA but I really
wasn't I think is is also telling them
but yeah I think that they sort of treat
that as a trade secret they say well if
we reveal how we did that and that helps
them evade
you know our our techniques there yeah
yeah exactly this BAM yeah yeah and
there are some there are some accounts
there's a there's a project that's
funded by the German Marshall Fund that
tries to track Russian bots that are
still active um I don't think they're
affiliated with the IRA but they've got
you know they look at things like you
know are they active during the daylight
hours in Moscow I'm toothpaste st.
Peterburg st. Petersburg do they use
things like um what is it like uh
certain certain solace isms that are
particular to to Russian language right
so that's in English in terms of English
translation so the way the day that
sometimes that's done but yeah we're not
exactly sure and that's definitely a
point of criticism I think yes so one of
the things so the vast majority of the
accounts the the the twenty over 2700
most of them had very few followers but
there were a few that had a lot of
followers so ten GOP had a lot that got
lots of retweets you can see here you
know one example an example of that is
if you take a really close look at these
ones right so Pam amor is getting
hundreds of retweets per tweet but if
you look at Robbie Delaware he's getting
nothing like one like here very little
is going on here here even though
Cleveland online has thirteen point
eight thousand followers if you look at
these tweets not a whole lot of reaction
here and then for my flowers got a
little bit four nine four six but
certainly less than uh so again they
didn't differ a lot in popularity yes
that is an excellent empirical question
which I aim to the two answers where you
buy you can buy followers but um what
like a good question would be what would
be the point
I mean you figure if he's going to buy
your followers you
the the goal of Vinnie I mean this is
this is sort of taken from so the
traditional Papa get from traditional
disinformation theory the goal is to
reach real people so if you're gonna buy
followers why not buy them for all of
your accounts why would you leave all of
your accounts with zero followers or
very small numbers of followers why not
make them all 10,000 they're there it's
really cheap you can do it for very
little money so the fact that there were
so many of these accounts that a few
followers tells me that the ones that
actually hid had significant numbers of
yes right well so in the in the future
research that I am to do I will address
that impact question directly I can sort
of look at that when I'm considering the
number of retweets that that these
messages gotten so that's one sort of
very small way that I can get at that
you know to the general question of
impact I would say that you know so yes
maybe it's true that like you know
Russian boss didn't sway the election
right I mean that's I think I think I'm
probably you know they have none of our
research but like I'm pretty comfortable
saying that but you know this is only
you know the epistemological situation
in which we find ourselves
he's one that is very you know
vulnerable to this kind of manipulation
and it's because it hasn't worked before
it doesn't mean that a more refined more
sophisticated version of this couldn't
work in the future
so there's acne then there's also the
piece that with electoral margins being
as thin as they are it doesn't take a
whole lot of nudging to like flip things
in another direction so I think that
even those possibilities make this
worthy of study and so and I also think
just generally speaking that there's a
whole lot of stuff to study and people
can study the things that they want to
study as long as they can make a case
for it and I think the case for this is
it's pretty strong especially when you
consider the implications of what might
happen if they succeed in a really big
way yes under on this last semester and
you know really the only way to spot
fake news or one of the best ways to
spot fake news is through consensus
right so finding corroborating sources
being using the skills that journalists
use every day but and also accepting
that that's never going to be perfect
right so even professional journalists
get hoodwinked on occasion right well I
think it's also important to consider
you know the the converse right so going
so far toward the realm of you know
paranoia that you sort of see agent
provocateur is everywhere you look and
that's one potential effect of the IRAs
revelation right because now you know
I've even started doing this like wow
could this person be some kind of
foreign agent if they're you know
tweeting in a way that seems a little
bit off you know I've started to looking
at my social media feeds a little bit
differently because of this and so
that's the sort of second order effect
and I think this might have and you can
also generalize that to the fake news
when I'm not a huge fan of that term but
you know if you want to use it I think
there is a sense in which now you look
at things that seem like a little bit
off me like this because that's really
real but I think and the last thing I'll
say about it is you have to give you
have to be willing to suspend judgment
right and a willing you have a
willingness to apply provisional
acceptance and a willingness to revoke
that upon the revelation of future you
know facts that are not presently yet
linked and to be okay with that right
you know it's like in science right
everything is provisional right
anything can be overturned with you know
some you know additional evidence and so
and so it is with news information that
after with politics well the initial
reports on this were actually sourced by
moles and the organization right so so
moles like some ex employees and so
before they actually spot remember the
first stories of this come on 2014 we
don't realize who these folks are until
the end of 2017 so you know there was
sort of this story circulating around
that they're these Russian Russian
organization out there started tweeting
we don't know who exactly they are
Twitter leaves II counts up Facebook
leaves he counts up you know they buy
all these ads and post all this you know
fake you know so grassroots looking
stuff and so we did take some time well
it did take time you know from the first
stories that started to emerge into 2014
to the revelation of those accounts at
the end of 2017
and I think how they knew about it was
the insiders that actually came out and
provided the documentation of this which
was corroborated by a number of
journalists so so yeah I mean that this
was not instantaneous when he means yeah
so the New York Times piece the major
New York Times piece came up in 2050
melts by Adrienne Chen 2014 piece was in
BuzzFeed and I give you the actually up
that guy's name if you want that
where was that that was on that that was
on the thing with the big yes so that's
a max said on CD do n who wrote the
BuzzFeed piece in 2014 which was the
first as far as I can tell major
english-language piece describing the
IRA and its activities they should do
the research that's what I'm trying to
do right so I mean it's you know we all
know people who make claims without the
empirical but is supported right this
data this data won't became public very
very recently and so and even if that's
true you know that's not to say this
could again that's not that say that
this couldn't happen again oh yeah I
totally agree with that right so yeah so
I completely agree with that I mean what
I would I would argue that its
importance doesn't turn on that
particular factor so but I've seen that
frame happen a lot rights because that
all I didn't affect the election so who
cares right
well there's a lot of we sit together
right there's the fact that Russia has
not done in fact other states could do
this there's the fact that people might
want to know that folks are out there
you know trying to mutilate their
opinion for serve dishes so we have
reasons of you know international
relations doing dealing with foreign
States right so I think that and as far
as the impact goes it's interesting and
I think valuable to try to figure out
even if overall the effect is low the
effect could have been stronger among
certain populations right so looking at
the overall effect I think is somewhat
misleading when this was a targeted
operation we know that there were
specific groups that were that were that
were at the business end of that so you
know I'm at that point I think is is
certainly valid but I wouldn't take it
too far
yes so I'm hoping and I don't and so
this is you know like I'm hoping to
prevail upon the good graces of a
journal editor who sees the value of
getting us out in relatively short order
so my pitch is basically like this is
important you know and somebody who
believes that peer-reviewed work has a
role early some peer-reviewed work has a
role to instruct and inform the public
right some during letters are like well
we only do this for my own little you
know community of practice and community
of research and that's fine but there
are others who say well I want my
research to have an impact I want my
research that in fact will be on the
field especially when the topic is so
important so really I'm just going to
look for folks and all I've been contact
I've been tacticals and journal editors
and some of them have expressed some
interest but I'm trying to figure out I
mean obviously you know do the nature of
peer review there are no guarantees and
I'm not gonna ask for that but you know
somebody who under the right
circumstances might be willing to you
know send it to some of their faster
reviewers and you know and try to do do
what they can within the restrictions of
peer review - you know like for example
speed up the production process or
something like that so yeah so that
might be and then one that might be one
way to go about it would be to try to
find somebody a journalist or something
who could co-write this with me that
might be worth worth doing and so yeah I
could think about I can think about
doing that I could have a colleague who
did something very similar so I'm a I'm
a
that but um the discussions go we'll see
yes you mentioned that they have agendas
that were somewhat contradictory well I
think really the answer is both right
because on the one hand you had so
really the only sort of consistent
through line was was like we don't like
Hillary right so there's Pro Bernie
stuff there's Pro dill Stein stuff there
was pro Trump stuff there was stuff
about how terrible cops are was stuff oh
how great cops were so there was there
were things that were directly
contradictory well the only thing they
really didn't seem to touch at all when
the election major issues in terms of
election was they never almost never
posted anything that was Pro Hillary so
it may have been oriented toward regime
change you know they say look they say a
lot about you know sowing chaos trying
to provoke polarization part of the
difficulty is it's very difficult to
infer intent outside of the data to
which we have access and the data
themselves are weird right I mean
they're just like it's hard to make
sense of them and so part of this
process is I'm glad you're asking these
questions but I'm trying to figure out
the frame to put on this that helps make
some sense out of what they were trying
to do but I'm also a little bit wary of
like you know being being a little too
sort of it burns more than is warranted
on the basis of the data that I have so
yes
research I suppose that's possible you
know the Internet research agency itself
is somewhat already right so I mean if
you if you accept the premise that what
they were doing was pretty propaganda
right and and they are media is doing to
them what we're talking about there so
such a small scale thing is this I
wonder if well I mean I suppose there's
no reason it couldn't be both right so
if it has an impact you know fantastic
we are fulfilling that misinformation
role in terms of visiting harm upon
enemies and benefits upon the source but
you know I would assume that to whatever
extent that's true it's an iterative
process so we certainly saw that over
the course of the of the IRS activity
period over these three years right so
I'm pretty sure I need to do this
analysis but I'm pretty sure that the
rate of retweets went up a lot simply
because of the election so they were
able to learn it would be one might
infer at least then they were able to
learn what worked and also I did some
conversations on a mailing list of them
on fake news mailing lists said that
before the IRA started there was some a
Russians sort of media analytics firm
that pinpointed the most divisive issues
that then was fed into the process of
generating identities for these accounts
so there was certainly some research on
the front end if that source can be
believed and I can only assume that
whatever sort of analytics they were
looking at in the social media hand was
then cycled back into the operations
that they did to try to improve and try
not trying to try to get more reactions
out of folks but again I'm only on this
side of it so I have no idea
which is totally fine all right
[Applause]